welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain I'd like to introduce dr.
Franz Schon dr. Chen holds a JD PhD and
is the executive director of the Harvard
MGH Center for law brain and behavior he
is also an associate professor of law
and a McKnight presidential fellow at
the University of Minnesota for a
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr. shed will be presenting in our
neuroethics tract on from lab to law
neuroscience in the courtroom my name is
dr. rush natashia and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
what up seminar presented by libraries
we would also like to extend our special
thanks to the program directors of the
brain initiative and in particular dr.
James Mack for their efforts in
organizing this session before we begin
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting
questions during the presentation simply
click on the ask a question box located
at the far left of your screen and type
your questions in the drop-down box for
this presentation we will be offering a
unique opportunity to directly discuss
the ethical considerations of using new
neuro technologies in a live panel Q&A
which will take place today at 11:20
a.m. Pacific time and 2:20 p.m. Eastern
Time
any questions that we don't have time to
address to our speakers will be answered
by email following the presentation this
presentation is educational and thus
offers free containing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without any further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. Francis
Shen
well thank you for that introduction and
it's a pleasure to be with you here
today
my name is Francis Shen and I'm going to
talk about the connection from lab to
law neuroscience in the court room
before we get going I just want to note
that I have no conflicts or relevant
financial relationships and I want to
start by talking about
the motto of my lab I run a neural law
lab and our motto is every story is a
brain story the challenge is that right
now as you've seen throughout the day
every story is not fully understood and
in some ways fully incomplete brain
story and this challenge that we know
something but not enough is gonna prove
real each a problematic for the use of
neuroscience and courtroom because it's
unclear when a particular type of
neuroscience is ready for particular
legal use and it's already happening so
let's get started a couple of words of
context two points really the first is
that law can facilitate or hinder
advances in understanding brain circuits
by its regulatory structure I won't talk
a lot about this today with every
researcher in brain knows that if they
want to get funding they'd better be in
line with NIH regulations NIH funding
priorities and Congress or the states or
funding agencies can decide whether or
not the fun certain areas are not um
there is another way however and this is
what I will talk about today which
neuroscience and walk interact and that
is that advances in the brain and our
understanding of brain circuitry you're
really fundamentally shift legal
doctrine and legal practice we're
beginning to see that why is that the
case why should law a discipline that
doesn't traditionally engage with
neuroscience here about the brain and
the answer speaks to the uniqueness of
the brain initiative and it's unique
from other efforts very important at
first that NIH is doing the brain is
special and here's why this is a
headline from a recent short piece that
my colleague Owen Jones wrote sort of
how to begin in law and neuroscience and
what we said was not that a lot in law
hinges on how long's work and we didn't
say that a lot in law Inge's on how
parts work what we said is that a lot in
law hinges on how brains work now that
may seem obvious but it's really
foundational and it's true and it's even
been recognized in NIH brain itself so
in brain 2025 a vision part of the
recognition towards the end of that
report was that brain science entails
special ethical considerations including
whether some of these neuropsychiatric
disorders may be used to judge
accountability in the legal system or
whether or not judging and 10r
accountability in a legal system as an
implication of brain science and an even
recognize that we might want to do
outreach to legal practitioners let's
explore some of these ideas as we do
we're gonna face some foundational
challenges these include the differences
in how law and science operate
neuroscience is complex and
probabilistic that's why we have error
bands that's why we say something might
be related something else but more
research is needed law is simple and
binary often for instance you're either
guilty or you're not guilty either you
need to pay or you don't
another way in which they differ is that
neuroscience is universal it's what's
allowed these global collaboration
because studying dendrite here is
probably the same as studying a dendrite
in another country not so with law the
law of various county to county city to
city country the country how can these
two work together open question
neuroscience at its best is
collaborative
again you see global collaborations and
data sharing law in many contexts
certainly in the United States context
is adversarial this poses challenges as
well finally neuro signs in many ways
and especially brain 2025 places an
emphasis on breakthrough discovery big
moonshots that would just change our
understanding of who we are and how to
go about understanding the brain and yet
law really emphasizes following
precedent doing today what we did
yesterday
maintaining this sort of quarter so
these are some of the ways and the
tensions between neuroscience and law
keep them in mind as we walk through
this neuroscience and law field breathe
further things to remember quit first
neuroscience I think does have
transformative potential for law if it
is used properly that's a big if which
leads to the second observation that
currently the field of law and
neuroscience is emerged in part to
delineate between the appropriate versus
the inner
and premature uses of neuroscience
separating wheat from chaff and then
finally it's worth noting that this
future in this field is really uncertain
you could be a part of it indeed
dialogue like this and I think the NIH
for including us legal conversation in
today's conversation this sort of
dialogue is really important if the
future is uncertain and it's gonna
depend on how we talk about it what we
did so let's again set some some context
here and I've given a Venn diagram here
of three different circles one our
district Neuroscience advances where's
the science going then I have asked
whether or not those advances and basic
science will be clinically relevant and
for the MDS in our community we're
changing the way that we treat and
understand and cure disease and then
I've added a box here or circle to ask
whether or not some of this is legally
relevant
does it change legal doctrine or legal
practice well importantly and
appropriately almost all NIH funded
research is not aimed to be legally
relevant those will see some of it is
its aim to be clinically relevant we
want to improve human health and we
might do this through better
understanding of human brain structure
function there could be though there's
not funding priority to do this funding
neuroscience research that isn't about
curing disease but is about changing the
legal system and a shining example of
that would be what if we had a
multi-million dollar investment in the
neuroscience of lie detection again you
wouldn't make anyone more healthy but
you might fundamentally change the
system and there the way we administer
justice and so this leaves us in the
current a situation which is that in the
short run neuroscience that is designed
for clinical purposes for instance of
improving identification and treatment
of Alzheimer's disease will find its way
into the legal system indirectly that is
let's say that we have a case for
grandma or grandpa or some other elderly
relative has recently changed their will
in a way that is concerning to others
around that person well the legal system
might be brought in to figure out
whether or not that individual had the
requisite legal capacity it changed
their will or to confer a contract
and in those legal Massa nations
increasingly we'll see neuroscience why
because that neuroscience funded by NIH
coming through the clinic will be used
to help the legal system reach the
conclusions
it needs the reach so I've given you a
lot of context but what exactly is
neuroscience and law what sorts of
questions and topics are being asked we
can think of this in I think four
different buckets there are
intersections sort of in the governance
and regulation side there are
intersections in the courtroom that's
what I'll talk about most
there are intersection in legislatures
Congress and state legislatures are
incorporating neuroscience into the laws
that they're making and then there are
some deep philosophical and legal
concepts I just want to flag some of
these for you that we don't have time to
go into them so you get a sense of the
breadth of which neuroscience may affect
law governance and regulation well what
about neuroscience intellectual property
data privacy and data sharing is a huge
issue how do we properly inform subjects
what are they a regulatory structures
for the pathways to market form
brand-new neuro technology for
direct-to-consumer neuro technology how
do you protect consumers while still
allowing them to try new neuro
scientific devices these are the sorts
of questions that are happening in the
governance and regulation stream they're
important they won't have time to talk
about them more today there are also
issues in the context of court room I'll
mention them now and then I'll give you
a few examples here in the second half
then we've already seen in US courts and
elsewhere in other countries Asian
avowing brain-based lie detection memory
detection that eyewitness memory
criminal behavior in my brain makes me
do it pain and suffering and miscibility
of evidence but how does the
neuroscience of trauma affect legal
adjudication how do we understand jury
and judge decision making in
neuroscience how I don't handle
traumatic brain injury how do we make
these determinations about whether or
not someone had capacity or competency
these and so much more are happening in
courtrooms in this country in the United
States and worldwide a third area in
which we're seeing a lot of activity our
legislatures legislators are free to use
all sorts of information when they crack
public policy and increasingly it turns
out they're turning to neuroscience how
are they doing this in defining life and
death from brain death with fetal pain
in distinguishing or ending the
distinction between physical injuries
and mental injuries providing rights
based on neural development taking away
rights based on neurodegeneration
determining ages for adult or juvenile
punished punishment deciding whether to
allow or modify solitary confinement
providing services to those who are
mentally handicapped and those who are
brain injured and again so much more
happening in legislatures informed
increasingly by neuroscience and then
finally it's worth noting and certainly
don't have time to answer some of these
questions but there are big questions
out there that neuroscience challenges
the law to re-envision for instance what
constitutes a disability what is normal
how much choice doesn't add it or do any
of us have do we have free will and does
it matter if the law and what is that
relationship between mind brain and
behavior and as we reimagine and re
understand that relationship should the
law change as I said there's so much
more here I wish I could talk to you
more but I can so I'm just gonna focus
on a few courtroom cases here's what you
should know about what's already
happening in US courts first of all
there are already a lot of cases and
we're getting more data from NIDA
Farahani data from Professor David mor
showing that different types of
neuroscience PET scans MRI EEG PET scan
fMRI Huey EEG are showing up in court
second note won't go into the history
but it's worth noting that there have
been some previous iterations earlier in
the twentieth century of neuroscience
and law and policy intersecting written
about this in a article the overlooked
history of neural law
bottom line it wasn't always pretty
Third Point but question given that
we're already seeing this evidence in is
not in neuroscience could appear in the
courtroom because it is but whether a
particular type of neuroscience is
appropriate for a particular legal
question and final context
note evidence as I mentioned before
always occurs within an adversarial
system but a big study I did of the use
of neuroscience and legislation remember
I mentioned that policymakers are using
them the bottom line of this result that
neuroscience isn't revolutionising
legislators ideas as much as reinforcing
their pre-existing ones that is you're a
legislature a legislature and you like a
certain policy and neuroscience helps to
support your position you really like
that neuroscience by contrast if it
doesn't support your position you might
call that neuroscience question let's
move into these cases here are some pin
bits
know it you interested hopefully and to
show you that neuroscience is having an
effect and then raise questions about
whether or not it should be used in
these different ways so the US Supreme
Court has taken notice of neuroscience
in a series of cases under the Eighth
Amendment that ask is it cruel and
unusual to do the following things to
juveniles is it cruel and unusual in
Roper V Simmons to have the death
penalty for juveniles yes it was world
cruel and unusual in part based on brain
science Ranbir's Florida is a cruel and
unusual to have life without the
possibility of parole for a non-homicide
offender yes in part they reached that
answer based on brain science finally
Miller V Alabama is it cruel and unusual
even for a homicide offender to have
automatic life about the possibility of
parole again answer yes and again by
reference to neuroscience in part the
neuroscience they are speaking both to
the age of culpability that adolescents
are by virtue of their age less culpable
and their brain development and secondly
that their brain development suggests a
more amenable
in other areas of the criminal law we've
seen it too we've seen versions of my
brain made me do it
did my neurons make me do it here's an
example of a case herbert weinstein 55
year old advertising executive throws
his wrangles his wife then to make it
look like a suicide throws her out the
13th story building of their New York
apartment building he was going to plead
insanity and he said he couldn't
appreciate right from wrong and he
wanted to introduce to the jury this
image on the left the Mr
skin on the right the PET scan showing a
large cyst an arachnoid cyst right up in
the
frontal lobes his argument this cyst
changed the way that my prefrontal
cortex was operating in such a way that
I couldn't appreciate right from wrong
and couldn't control by violent impulses
the question the judge had to ask what
should a jury be able to see this sort
of image does is around the country are
asking these sorts of questions and it's
challenging because we have absolutely
no research on what the relationship is
between this sort of brain abnormality
and the sorts of legally relevant
behavior ie strangling your wife and
throwing her out the 13-story window of
your apartment building again open
questions we know something about the
brain you know something about those
frontal lobes but we don't know this and
yet we're seeing them in courtrooms
we're also seeing in criminal sentencing
you might ask yourself wait a second
when any of this brain science actually
matter in the legal system or was this
sort of additional evidence that just
gets added to the pile well here's a
case to make you think this is a picture
of Grady Nelson mr. Nelson it was
uncontroverted was found guilty of
stabbing his wife 70 times killing her
attempting to kill his stepchildren
thankfully they survived and he had a
litany of other crimes wasn't a bad but
was not a nice guy and the only question
this happened in the state of Florida in
2010 was whether or not he would receive
the death penalty or life without the
possibility of parole the jury that had
to decide that was 12 in men and women
and they split six six and so mr. Nelson
did not go to death row but to life
without the possibility of parole and
introduced in that case was this
evidence you see that image of a QTE
g-scan so-called brain map the argument
was that mr. Nelson had a broken brain
three of the jurors after that case
spoke with the local newspaper I'm gonna
give you their quotes here's what they
said about that brain evidence juror
Delores can in a hospital secretary
quote when the brain evidence came in
the facts about the QED EEG some of us
changed our mind
second juror John Howard Airport Fleet
Services worker that decision that brain
evidence turned my decision all the way
around the technology really swayed me
after seeing the brain scans I was
convinced this guy had some sort of
brain problem now they didn't all buy it
juror Leon Benbow
mailman quote all that scientific
testimony that was a waste of taxpayer
money that's phony there's nothing wrong
with that guy's brain so we're seeing it
show up again ask ourselves is it
appropriate and how would we know just
one last case
lie detection what if we had brain based
lie detection well I'm on record of
saying we're not ready yet but that
didn't stop
Lawrence MRI pictured here from
introducing it in his case the
government had to show that he defrauded
Medicare he was building in ways that
seem to be fraudulent they had to show
that he knowingly did it and mr. summer
I wanted to get an expert to testify dr.
Steve Lincoln who after scanning some
aroused brain several times was ready to
report to a jury that quote dr. Sandoz
brain indicates he is telling the truth
in regards not cheating or defrauding
the government there was a
day-and-a-half
hearing as to whether or not a jury
should hear this evidence at the end of
the day judge Pham in Tennessee and I
think he was right
included that at least in this early
stage in its development fMRI based lie
detection does not satisfy the
requirements rule 702 is the evidentiary
rule government scientific evidence in
federal courts it wasn't ready for
primetime but we are gonna see more and
more of this I have suggested in some
other work that neuroscience evidence in
the future might look like instant
replay just as today we don't replay
most plays in games but we do some and
so images like this when the stakes are
high when it's a scoring play or the
foots on the line this image wouldn't
have been possible 50 years ago because
this technology wasn't available
similarly today in many cases right on
the borderline we may want to go to
neuroscience to help the legal system
adjudicate so where is this all going
well let me just say a word on the
future of neuroscience at law and let me
do so by going back 200 years to a
seminal work in law this is a work by
Oliver Wendell Holmes jr. called the
path of law and a whole is recognized
that if law adheres only to precedent
and only does in this year what it did
last year there's a slippery slope and
here's what he said it is revolting to
have no better reason for a rule of law
then it was so laid down at the time of
Henry
because if you think about it that's
what happens in law we do what this year
what we did last year and last year what
we did the year before and so on and so
forth until you get back down to the
tunnel under Edith Porter Holmes went on
to say it is still more revolting if the
grounds upon which it was laid down have
banished blocks then what neuroscience
today is doing is challenging law to
reexamine its assumptions some of which
have been around for centuries and as we
re-examine these assumptions the law I
think is likely to change the future
health law is one that will likely
involve neuroscience but how that
remains to be seen
I thank you for your time and look
forward to the discussion later thank
you dr. Chen for that excellent
presentation please remember to submit
your questions for dr. Shannon will
answer them in the live Q&A coming up
next please join us for this unique
opportunity to interact directly with
dr. Shannon and our other experts dr.
Ramos dr. Hendrix dr. protein and dr.
fine singer to discuss mere ethics and
the ethical considerations of using new
newer technologies hope to see an axe